I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Get out your fakie stashes, everybody, because it's time for Branch Wars. Fakie stash day on Office, ladies. It's season four, episode 10, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Joss Whedon. There's so much good fake stash. Stash is lingo for mustache. Oh, Jenna, thank you. Thank you for breaking that down. I wanted to break it down. I break down everything
我是詹娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。大家拿好你们的假胡子，因为“分社之战”时间到了。《办公室》女郎的假胡子日。这是第四季第10集，由敏迪·卡林编剧，乔斯·韦登执导。有这么多的假胡子。胡子（stash）是小胡子（mustache）的行话。噢，詹娜，谢谢你。谢谢你剖析这个。我想剖析一下。我剖析一切
on Office, ladies. It's what we do. I'm gonna hit you with a summary. Guys, Karen is back. She is now the regional manager of the Utica branch, and she offers Stanley a higher paying job to leave Scranton. Guess what Michael's reaction is to that? He flips out. Yes. Very much so. Meanwhile, Pam, Oscar, and Toby have created a finer things club. Ooh, it's finer things club. You're so excited. Andy tries to join, but he's rejected. And Michael and Dwight trick Jim into going on a sales call, but they actually take him to Utica to prank Karen as a revenge for trying to poach Stanley. That's a lot. This was a big episode for us. I mean, anytime we traveled, you know, it was a big deal. This is something I have to
在《办公室》女郎节目中。这就是我们的工作。我要给你来个总结。伙计们，凯伦回来啦。她现在是尤蒂卡分社的地区经理，她给斯坦利提供了一份薪水更高的工作来让他离开斯克兰顿。你们猜迈克尔对此有什么反应？他气疯了。是的。非常激动。与此同时，彭妮、奥斯卡和托比成立了一个上流社会俱乐部。哦，这是上流社会俱乐部。你太兴奋了。安迪试图加入，但被拒绝了。迈克尔和德怀特捉弄吉姆去参加一个销售电话会议，但他们实际上把他带到了尤蒂卡去捉弄凯伦，以此报复她试图挖走斯坦利。这信息量真大。对我们来说，这一集很重要。我的意思是，每次我们出差，你知道的，这都是件大事。这是我必须
say to you. I have to get this off my chest, Jenna. There's been a few times that you say I'm going to hit you with the summary. Okay. And every time the only thing going through my brain is hit me with the summary. I'm gonna hit you with a summary. What song are you singing? I'm trying to sing hit me with your best shot. Oh, I thought you were singing hit me with your summary. Did you hear that? That was Brittany. Oh, yeah. Well, anyway, I hear Joan jet. Well, I'm glad you got that off your chest because God forbid you would have had to carry that through this whole podcast. You know what? It was weighing on me and I feel lighter. Good. Fast back. Number one, like I said earlier, this episode was written
对你说的。我必须把这件事吐出来，詹娜。有好几次你说我要给你来个总结。好吧。每一次我脑子里唯一转悠的念头就是“给我来个总结吧”。我要给你来个总结。你在唱什么歌？我正试图唱“用你最好的一击打击我”。哦，我还以为你在唱“用你的总结打击我”呢。你听见了吗？那是布兰妮。哦，对了。总之，我听到的是琼·杰特。好吧，我很高兴你把这块心病吐出来了，因为上帝保佑，如果你必须带着这个想法录完整期播客就糟了。你知道吗？这一直压在我心头，现在我觉得轻松多了。很好。趣事。第一，就像我刚才说的，这一集是
by Mindy Kaling. This was the seventh episode she had written and she was nominated for Outstanding Writing in a Comedy Series in the 2008 NAACP Image Awards for this episode. Yay, Mindy! Yay, Mindy! When I was looking at Mindy's award history, I found this. What? I mean, Mindy has been nominated up and down. Emmys and things and she's winning things she's celebrated. Deservedly so. The lady is very talented. In 2013, Time Magazine listed Mindy as one of the 100 most influential people in the world. Dang, Mindy! You guys have to understand, like Mindy was on the office with us and we're all like just getting our hair and makeup done and she's in her 20s and we're just being girlfriends and
由敏迪·卡林编剧的。这是她编写的第七集，她凭借这一集获得了2008年NAACP形象奖喜剧类杰出编剧提名。耶，敏迪！耶，敏迪！当我查看敏迪的获奖历史时，我发现了这个。什么？我的意思是，敏迪获得了无数提名。艾美奖之类的，她赢得了奖项，她受到了赞誉。实至名归。这位女士非常有才华。2013年，《时代》杂志将敏迪列为全球100位最具影响力的人物之一。天哪，敏迪！你们必须明白，敏迪曾和我们一起出演《办公室》，我们当时都只是在弄头发和化妆，她才二十多岁，我们只是作为女性朋友在一起，而
now she is just a force, just a powerhouse and we always knew that she was super smart and talented and just this is awesome. I love that all her dreams have come true. Yes. And she's a mom and I know that was a big dream. I know. I'm just so happy for her. Mindy, we love you. We're here for it, Mindy. We're here for it. We will be your girl gang cheering you on. Super proud. Alright, fast fact number two. Okay. Fan question from Ryan, Annika and Vivian Freutman. Where did you film the Utica office? Oh, some cantipedia coming. I feel it. You know it. It's a location breakdown. So, Ann, you know, we've talked a lot about how oftentimes we would build a temporary set for another office like we built corporate
现在她简直是一股力量，一个强人，我们一直都知道她超级聪明、极具才华，这真是太棒了。我很高兴她所有的梦想都成真了。是的。她成了一位母亲，我知道那是她最大的梦想。我知道。我真是为她感到高兴。敏迪，我们爱你。我们支持你，敏迪。我们全力支持你。我们将做你的啦啦队女孩，为你呐喊助威。超级骄傲。好吧，趣事之二。好的。来自瑞恩、阿尼卡和维维安·弗罗特曼的粉丝提问。尤蒂卡办公室是在哪里拍摄的？哦，坎蒂百科全书要来了。我感觉到了。你懂的。这是一个外景剖析。所以，安，你知道的，我们讨论过很多次，通常我们会为另一个办公室搭建一个临时布景，比如我们在仓库舞台上搭建了
over on our warehouse stages. Well, Kent told me that the size of the Utica Dunder Mifflin branch was just way too big and way too costly. So, they took it on location. They found a business park in Canoga Park and this building had a very large empty office suite. So, our set decorators just went in and decorated it to be Dunder Mifflin Utica. And then they also filmed all the parking lot scenes in that same Canoga Park business lot. I remember we were on the road for this episode because it also meant I had a few days off in the middle of the week. That was always very exciting. When you would read a script and there were a bunch of characters who went somewhere and you didn't go, you were like, oh my gosh,
公司总部。好吧，肯告诉我，尤蒂卡邓德米夫林分社的规模实在是太大了，成本也太高了。所以，他们把摄制组搬到了实景地。他们在卡诺加公园找到了一个商业园区，这栋建筑有一个非常大的空置办公套房。所以我们的布景师直接进去把它装饰成了邓德米夫林尤蒂卡分社。然后他们还在同一个卡诺加公园的商业区拍摄了所有的停车场场景。我记得我们为了这一集在路上奔波，因为这也意味着我在周中有了几天假。那总是非常令人兴奋。当你读到剧本时，发现有一堆角色去了某处而你没去，你就会想，哦天哪，
doctor's appointments. What else can I do that I can normally never do? Exactly. Well, we did not go to this business park for this episode, but I end up going back in Lecture Circuit because we go back to Utica. That was an episode that was also written by Mindy Kaling. It was crazy because the set decorators, after they build a set somewhere, we have to leave. They have to break it all down. But before they do, they take detailed pictures, like just extensive photos of every nook, every desk, every placement of every item on the off chance that we have to go back and recreate it. And that's what they had to do with the Utica branch.
去看医生的预约。我还能做什么平时绝对做不到的事呢？没错。好吧，我们这一集没有去这个商业园区，但在《巡回演讲》中我又回去了，因为我们要回尤蒂卡。那一集也是由敏迪·卡林编剧的。这太疯狂了，因为布景师在某个地方搭建了布景之后，我们就得离开。他们必须把它们全部拆除。但在拆除之前，他们会拍详细的照片，比如每个角落、每张桌子、每件物品摆放位置的大量照片，以防万一我们要回去重新搭建。这就是他们对尤蒂卡分社所做的事情。
Yeah, it's pretty fascinating. They have these binders, the different departments, and here in makeup do this as well. So, if there were people that were guest actors in the Utica branch, they match their looks. But also, our set designers would do this. And I looked through one of these binders one time, Jenna, and it is so thorough. I was so impressed. Yeah. Just photo after photo after photo. And they take all the stuff and they store it in that big warehouse that we've talked about and they label it all. It's really crazy.
是的，这太迷人了。他们有这些文件夹，不同的部门，化妆间这里也是这么做的。所以，如果尤蒂卡分社有客串演员，他们就会配合他们的造型。而且，我们的布景设计师也会这样做。有一次我翻阅了其中一个文件夹，詹娜，它是如此详尽。我印象太深刻了。是的。一张又一张又一张的照片。他们把所有的东西都拿走，存放在我们聊过的那座大仓库里，并把它们全部贴上标签。这真的很疯狂。
It was very organized and I liked it. I liked it too. You know, I love good organization. I know you do, Layla. And I know you liked it, Angela, because it involved a lot of bins. Bins and I love photos. I will look through any photo album. This is a little Kinsey tidbit about myself. I love looking at pictures and I don't need to know the people in them. I remember one time when we were getting married, we were looking at wedding photographers and they would send us their other albums so we could see their style.
它非常有条理，我很喜欢。我也很喜欢。你知道的，我喜欢井井有条。我知道你喜欢，莱拉。我也知道你喜欢它，安吉拉，因为它涉及大量的储物箱。储物箱，而且我喜欢照片。我会翻阅任何一本相册。这是关于我自己的一个小金西花絮。我喜欢看照片，而且我不需要认识照片里的人。我记得有一次我们要结婚时，我们在寻找婚礼摄影师，他们会把其他相册发给我们，以便我们看看他们的风格。
Yeah. Fascinating. Total strangers. I love it. Well, I have some good follows for you on Instagram. Oh, yeah? Of just random photo albums? No, it's of wedding photos. I also, by the way, love looking at wedding photos. People are so happy on their wedding day. It's so joyous. It's joyous, Jenna, but then there's also a story. Like, every wedding has like, you know, the drunk uncle or the aunt who's alone on the dance floor. It's so good.
是的。太迷人了。完全是陌生人。我喜欢。嗯，我在Instagram上有一些不错的关注对象给你。哦，是吗？只是一些随机的相册？不，是婚纱照。顺便说一句，我也喜欢看婚纱照。人们在婚礼那天太开心了。太欢乐了。这很欢乐，詹娜，但其中也有一个故事。就像每场婚礼都有，你知道的，喝醉的叔叔或者独自在舞池里的阿姨。这太棒了。
And then the way they decorate their table, you know, you'll see, oh, look, they've got a pair of bicycles on top of their wedding cake. They must love cycling. Yes, they're the bicycle couple. Yeah. Okay, well, hit me up with some Instagrams. I will. You know what, guys, if you are interested, we'll link to it in our stories. I'll link my favorite bridal Instagram follows on Office Ladies Pod. Guys, that was quite a tangent and also an example of what a phone call might be between
然后他们装饰餐桌的方式，你会发现，哦，看，他们的婚礼蛋糕顶部有一对自行车。他们一定很喜欢骑自行车。是的，他们是自行车情侣。好吧，给我推荐几个Instagram账号。我会的。你知道吗，伙计们，如果你感兴趣，我们会在故事中链接它。我会在Office Ladies Pod上链接我最喜欢的婚礼Instagram关注对象。伙计们，刚才那是一段大段的题外话，也是安吉拉和我之间一通电话的缩影。
Angela and I. Next up is fastback number three. Since we're talking about the Utica branch, I actually thought this might be a good time to break down the various branches of Dunder Mifflin because, lady, I realize we've never done this. Oh, we need to do it. And oh, okay, I have something to piggyback off this, but you go first. Oh, okay. Well, we all know that the headquarters of Dunder Mifflin is in New York. Yes.
接下来是趣事之三。既然我们在谈论尤蒂卡分社，我其实觉得现在是个好时机来剖析一下邓德米夫林的各个分社，因为，女士，我意识到我们从来没做过这个。哦，我们得做这个。而且，哦，好吧，我有一些顺着这个话题要说的话，不过你先说。哦，好吧。嗯，我们都知道邓德米夫林的总部在纽约。是的。
But there are currently six active regional branches located across the United States. They are in Akron, Ohio, Nashua, New Hampshire, Rochester, Syracuse, and Utica, which are all in New York state, and Scranton, Pennsylvania. Now the company used to be much larger. You might remember in the Boys and Girls episode, Jan mentioned there used to be a branch in Pittsfield, but it was closed because they tried to unionize. And then in future episodes, we will learn about branches in Camden and Yonkers, which got closed due to the economy, and Buffalo, which was also closed.
但目前在美国各地设有六个活跃的地区分社。它们位于俄亥俄州阿克伦、新罕布什尔州纳舒华、罗切斯特、锡拉丘兹和尤蒂卡（这些都在纽约州），以及宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿。现在，这家公司过去规模要大得多。你可能还记得在《男孩与女孩》那一集里，简提到过去在皮茨菲尔德有一个分社，但因为它试图加入工会而关闭了。然后，在以后的剧集中，我们会了解到卡姆登和扬克斯的分社，它们由于经济原因而关闭，还有水牛城的分社也关闭了。
Buffalo, which was the home of Denise Stims, Angela's party planning committee rival. Closes down. Bye-bye, Denise. Oh, Angela Martin is so happy. And in our final season, we learned that there was also a branch in Binghamton. So there you go. There's a great deleted scene. It's a talking head where Michael goes through the other branches and sort of like gives you a little insight on how he remembers them. It's really
水牛城，那是丹尼斯·斯蒂姆斯（安吉拉的聚会策划委员会对手）的故乡。关闭了。再见，丹尼斯。哦，安吉拉·马丁太高兴了。在我们最后一季中，我们了解到宾厄姆顿也有一个分社。所以就这样。有一个很棒的删减片段。那是迈克尔回顾其他分社并对它们发表一点见解的独白镜头。这真的
funny. And Sam, I actually, I would love for you to play it right now. Utica is Snoozeville. Albany are the prepsters. Nashua, no parking. Akron is haunted. Camden is in a basement. Yonkers has a two hot girls. And here in Scranton, we are the cool guys. That is amazing. Yeah. Yep. He's sort of talking about the fact that like, why would Stanley want to leave here? We're the cool guys. And then he lists all the other branches and it just cracked me up. I love that Nashua, no parking. That made me laugh.
太搞笑了。山姆，其实，我很乐意你现在就播放它。尤蒂卡是个瞌睡虫聚集地。奥尔巴尼是预科生。纳舒华，没有停车位。阿克伦闹鬼。卡姆登在地下室。扬克斯有两个辣妹。而在斯克兰顿这里，我们才是酷哥。这太棒了。是的。没错。他其实是在谈论这样一个事实，即为什么斯坦利会想离开这里？我们是酷哥。然后他列出了所有其他分社，这把我逗乐了。我喜欢纳舒华没有停车位那个。这把我逗笑了。
I loved no parking too. That was my favorite. Lady, that's all I got. Well, those are great fast facts. I can't wait to get in this episode. I have some mini dive on the finer things club. Oh, I love that you mini dived on the finer things club. We will be back right after a break. All right. Well, we are back and there is an establishing shot of the Utica branch office. We see that it is in the Mohawk Valley Center. It's the 2,400 address, but at 2,480, there's
我也喜欢没有停车位。那是我的最爱。女士，我只有这些了。好吧，这些都是很棒的趣事。我迫不及待地想进入这一集了。我对上流社会俱乐部有一些微观深入探讨。哦，我很高兴你对上流社会俱乐部进行了微观深入探讨。我们休息一下，马上回来。好的，我们回来了，有一个尤蒂卡分社办公室的全景镜头。我们看到它在莫霍克山谷中心。地址是2400号，但在2480号，有
Wendell Flores of Utica. Oh, yeah. If you need flowers. We share an office with Bob Vance. They have the Flores shop next door. That's nice. That is nice. And then at 0.06 seconds, everybody, there is a plant at reception. Utica plant at reception alert. Green leafy plant. It's over Rolando's shoulder, but sitting right in front of him for everyone to enjoy is a big box of donuts.
尤蒂卡的温德尔·弗洛雷斯。哦，对。如果你需要花的话。我们和鲍勃·凡斯共用一个办公室。他们隔壁就是弗洛雷斯花店。那很好。那挺好的。然后在0.06秒处，大家注意，前台有一盆植物。尤蒂卡前台植物警报。绿色叶子植物。它在罗兰多的肩膀上方，但正对着他，供大家享用的是一大盒甜甜圈。
Yeah. What the heck? Pam has a candy dish on her desk. Rolando has some donuts and we got a lot of mail about these donuts, Angela. Did we? Yes, we did. Clay LaFriends, Kaylee Gassner, Zach Mutolo, Amber Lee, Danny Hamilton, and many others said those donuts are from Holland Farms, which is an awesome regional bakery in the
是的。搞什么鬼？彭妮的桌上有一个糖果盘。罗兰多有一些甜甜圈，我们收到了很多关于这些甜甜圈的邮件，安吉拉。是吗？是的，我们收到了。克莱·拉弗伦茨、凯利·加斯纳、扎克·穆托洛、安布尔·李、丹尼·汉密尔顿和许多其他人说这些甜甜圈来自霍兰农场，这是尤蒂卡地区一家超棒的地区面包店。
Utica area. Oh, they're famous for their jelly balls and half moon or black and white cookies. Everyone was very impressed. They said, we just loved whoever did research for this episode that they would dive the steep into Utica and have this amazing prop. That is Phil Shea. Phil Shea, regional prop alert. I want a jelly ball.
哦，他们以果冻球和半月饼（或黑白饼干）而闻名。每个人都印象深刻。他们说，我们只是喜欢为这一集做研究的人，他们会深入研究尤蒂卡并拥有这个令人惊叹的道具。那是菲尔·谢伊。菲尔·谢伊，地区道具警报。我想要一个果冻球。
That's what she said. Maybe she doesn't want a jelly ball. So far, Rolando's front reception is kind of kicking Pam's ass. You know what? I've seen donuts in our break room. I'm talking about front reception right now. Wow. Okay. I'm talking a tiny, tiny container of jelly beans versus a whole amazing box of donuts.
她就是这么说的。也许她不想要果冻球。到目前为止，罗兰多的前台有点把彭妮的风头盖过去了。你知道吗？我见过我们休息室有甜甜圈。我现在说的是前台。哇。好吧。我说的是一小罐果冻豆对阵一整盒惊艳的甜甜圈。
We don't know that Rolando put those donuts there. Anyone could have brought those in. Yes, he did. Rolando was played by Adam Jamal Craig. You guys might recognize him because he went on to play Dominic on NCIS Los Angeles. I reached out to him to see if he remembered doing this episode and if he had any memories he could share and he sent in this awesome audio clip. Sam, will you play the clip?
我们不知道那些甜甜圈是不是罗兰多放的。任何人都可以把它们带进来。是的，就是他放的。罗兰多由亚当·贾马尔·克雷格饰演。大家可能认出他来，因为他后来在《海军罪案调查处：洛杉矶》中饰演多米尼克。我联系了他，看他是否还记得拍摄这一集以及他是否有可以分享的回忆，他发来了这段精彩的音频剪辑。山姆，你能播放这个剪辑吗？
Yes. I totally remember spending a little bit of time shooting that with you guys and it was at the time it was my big break because I had done a few co-stars and that was a big deal and I just remember when I met the cast, one of the striking things was just how tall everyone was. Just generally a tall cast that doesn't really translate on screen, but I also remember how kind everyone was, it was a really warm set because a lot of people who don't work in show business don't realize that not every set is a warm set, but that set was a very
可以。我完全记得花了一点时间跟你们一起拍那场戏，在当时那是我的重大突破，因为我之前只客串过几次，那是一件大事。我只记得当我见到演员阵容时，最让人震惊的事情之一就是每个人的个子都太高了。总体来说是个高个子演员阵容，在屏幕上其实体现不出来，但我也记得每个人都超级亲切，那是一个非常温暖的剧组，因为很多不从事影视行业的人并不意识到并非每个剧组都是温暖的剧组，但那个剧组是一个非常
warm set. Everyone was really kind, but man it was a good time and what's funny is I've done things since then, not long after that I was on a series regular on a show, but still no one cared about that. They all were like, I heard your own office, when I get recognized, 99% of the time it's from the office, not anything else and so it was definitely a privilege and a joy to be like a part of that production. Aw, that is so sweet.
温暖的剧组。每个人都真的很善良，天哪，那段时光太美妙了。有趣的是，从那以后我做过其他事情，在那之后不久我就成了一部剧集的常规演员，但依然没有人关心那个。他们全都说：“我听说你演了《办公室》”，当我被认出来时，99%的时间都是因为《办公室》，而不是其他任何东西，所以能够成为那部制作的一部分绝对是一种特权和快乐。啊，太甜了。
You know, we did have a tall cast, we've talked a little bit about it, all these guys were really tall. Yeah, we had a lot of tall fellas. We really did. Adam also told me that he had not watched the whole office series until this last year. Oh yeah? And he was like, it is so good and I said, I know, we're re-watching it and I feel the same way.
你知道的，我们的演员阵容确实很高，我们之前也聊过一点，所有这些家伙个子都非常高。是的，我们有很多高个子帅哥。确实如此。亚当还告诉我，直到去年他才把整部《办公室》剧集看完。哦，是吗？他说：“这太棒了。”我说：“我知道，我们正在重温它，我也觉得一样。”
I know. It was so crazy. Well guys, Adam has a couple of cool projects he's working on now. One is called The Zook Line and it's a show about this obscure dance you do with a partner called the Brazilian Zook. Oh my gosh. Yes, Angela, if you go to his Instagram he has all of these amazing dance videos. He also has another show called The Grown Ups which is a roundtable discussion about
我知道。这太疯狂了。好吧，伙计们，亚当现在有几个很酷的项目在进行。其中一个叫做The Zook Line，这是一档关于一种与舞伴跳的晦涩舞蹈——巴西祖克舞（Brazilian Zook）的节目。哦，天哪。是的，安吉拉，如果你去他的Instagram，他有所有这些精彩的舞蹈视频。他还拥有另一个名为《成年人》的节目，这是一场关于时事的圆桌讨论，但视角是每个人都在试图在讨论时事时和平相处。我很感兴趣。是的。
current events but through the lens that everyone is trying to get along as they talk about current events. I was intrigued. Yeah. You can find both projects on his Instagram at AdamJ Craig. So check it out. And thank you, Adam. Thank you, Adam.
你可以在他的Instagram上找到这两个项目，账号是@AdamJCraig。去看看吧。谢谢你，亚当。谢谢你，亚当。
Well, now we're into Karen's office. I mean, she looks fantastic in this whole episode. I thought, Rashida, you looked gorgeous and her office is so professional and it cuts back between Karen and Michael's offices and I mean, come on, Michael is setting up a Ferris Bueller's prank. His desk is covered with like toys. Karen's desk looks like a badass boss lady. Yes.
好吧，现在我们来到了凯伦的办公室。我的意思是，她在这一整集里看起来棒极了。我觉得，拉什达，你看起来美极了，她的办公室太专业了。镜头在凯伦和迈克尔的办公室之间切换，我的意思是，拜托，迈克尔正在布置一个像《春天不是读书天》那样的恶作剧。他的桌子上堆满了玩具。凯伦的办公桌看起来就像一个厉害的女老板。是的。
An adult works in Karen's office. An adult work space. It's true. Well, we find out in this phone call that Karen is trying to hire someone from the Scranton branch. Yeah. She's like, hey, I'm glad we finally connected. We'd love to have you and who's she talking to?
一个成年人在凯伦的办公室工作。一个成人的工作空间。确实如此。好吧，我们在这次通话中发现凯伦正试图从斯克兰顿分社雇佣某人。是的。她说，嘿，我很高兴我们终于联系上了。我们很乐意让你加入，而她在跟谁说话？
Well, then we cut to Michael's office and like you said, he's got a dummy on his desk with this elaborate pulley system. Yeah. This whole pulley with the dummy hand and it hits the snoring sound. This is what Ferris did. So his parents thought he was home when he went and played hooky. Yeah. And Michael is so elated by this Dwight's excited.
好吧，然后镜头切到迈克尔的办公室，就像你说的，他的桌上有一个假人，还有一个精致的滑轮系统。是的。整个滑轮带着假人的手，还会发出打鼾的声音。这就是菲利斯（注：应为Ferris，即电影主角）做过的。所以他的父母以为他在家，而他却逃学了。是的。迈克尔对此兴奋不已，德怀特也很激动。
Stanley walks in and they're like, oh, Stanley, yes, we're going to test this out on you. And Stanley just no nonsense is like, Karen offered me more money. I'm going to Utica and he walks out. I know. He also has that great line where he says, why is you being asleep at your desk better than not being here? We had a fan question from Eric Wilson. I was wondering if you actually had a pulley system or if someone off camera was moving
斯坦利走了进来，他们说，哦，斯坦利，是的，我们要拿你来测试一下。斯坦利一点也不废话，直接说：“凯伦给我开了更高的薪水。我要去尤蒂卡了。”然后他走了出去。我知道。他还有那句极好的台词：“你趴在桌上睡觉为什么会比不在这里更好？”我们收到了来自埃里克·威尔逊的粉丝提问。我想知道你们是否真的有一个滑轮系统，还是镜头外有人在移动
the arm. No, it was a real pulley system. They really built that. Yeah. It really worked. And it was really funny. And when the hand goes up at the end, when Stanley leaves, that really happened. That's my favorite part.
手臂？不，那是一个真正的滑轮系统。他们真的搭建了那个。是的。它真的运作了。而且真的非常搞笑。当斯坦利离开时，手在最后抬起来的那一幕，那是真的发生了。那是我最喜欢的部分。
It's such a good button to the scene. I know. Well, Michael goes out into the bullpen and he breaks the news that Stanley is leaving Scranton for Utica. He's been offered more money and everybody applauds. Everyone's like, congratulations, Stanley. And Michael's like, no, no. Yeah.
这个场景的收尾太棒了。我知道。好吧，迈克尔走到办公区，宣布了斯坦利将离开斯克兰顿前往尤蒂卡的消息。他得到了更高的薪水，所有人都鼓掌了。每个人都说，恭喜你，斯坦利。而迈克尔却说，不，不。是的。
Michael's totally upset. Well, at two minutes, 12 seconds, you'll see how they got all of us in the shot. If you look over the camera, whips over to accounting and we did that thing where we all kind of come out from our desks. And at two minutes, 12 seconds, you guys can see my insane outfit, which is like a very floofy blouse with the vest, with the cap buttons. And right behind me is the baby jazz poster. It's backup.
迈克尔彻底心烦意乱。好吧，在2分12秒时，你会看到他们是如何把我们所有人都拍进镜头里的。如果你看一下，摄像机猛地转向会计部，我们做了那种从各自桌子后面走出来的动作。在2分12秒时，你们可以看到我那疯狂的行头，那是一件带有坎肩扣的马甲搭配非常蓬松的衬衫。紧挨着我身后的是那张婴儿爵士海报。它回归了。
It's backup. Oh, is there a deleted scene that explains this? No. Two minutes, 12 seconds, the baby poster is there. Jazz is back. Jazz is back. And I want the folks that love the background to also catch this moment. Two minutes, 17 seconds, when Michael announces that Stanley's leaving, Phyllis' face, she
它回归了。哦，有没有解释这一点的删减片段？没有。2分12秒，婴儿海报就在那里。爵士乐回归了。爵士乐回归了。我希望喜欢背景的观众也能抓住这个时刻。2分17秒，当迈克尔宣布斯坦利要离开时，菲利斯的脸，她
looks at him. It's so honest. And I'm telling you, in my opinion, Phyllis didn't know. You would think Phyllis and Stanley would have chatted about this, but the way Phyllis chose to play it was like, Stanley. Yes, betrayed. Well, just more like in awe, like, look at you go. Oh, I got to go back and look at that.
看着他。太真实了。我跟你说，在我看来，菲利斯事先并不知道。你本以为菲利斯和斯坦利会聊过这个，但菲利斯选择的表演方式就像是，斯坦利。是的，被背叛了。好吧，更像是敬畏，就像，看你走的。哦，我得回去看看那个。
Ooh, now we get into the Finers Things Club. Oh my God. I love how you are so excited about it. But did you hear that? This was my struggle, you guys. There's a series of talking heads that were deleted where everyone, like in the office is reacting to the Finers Things Club and like Meredith is annoyed, Angela is annoyed. I could not say, and I still can't, Finers Things, Finer Things Club.
哦，现在我们进入上流社会俱乐部了。哦，天哪。我喜欢你对它如此兴奋的样子。但你听见了吗？这就是我的挣扎，伙计们。有一系列被删减的独白镜头，办公室里的每个人都在对上流社会俱乐部做出反应，比如梅雷迪思觉得很烦，安吉拉觉得很烦。我无法说出，现在也依然说不好，“上流社会俱乐部”（Finer Things Club）。
You keep wanting to make it plural. You say Finers, Finers Things Club. I think this is a Southern thing. My mom does this too. We make things plural when they're not meant to be and then we make things singular when they're not meant to be. Like my mom always says, have you seen office, my daughter's on office? Instead of the office.
你总是想把它变成复数。你说的是“更精细的事物俱乐部”（Finers Things Club）。我觉得这是南方人的习惯。我妈妈也这样。当不该变复数时我们把它变成复数，当不该变单数时我们把它变成单数。就像我妈妈总是说：“你见过办公室吗？我女儿在《办公室》里演。”而不是“那个办公室”。
Yeah. And then I say Finers Things Club. Anyway, I'm going to put it in our stories because I found it. I could not say Finers Things, Finer, Finer Things Club, dang it. And also you learn that Angela Martin has been squashing other clubs and she's really annoyed because the Finer Things Club was not sanctioned by the party planning committee. Wow. You have to get your club sanctioned?
是的。然后我说“更精细的事物俱乐部”。不管怎样，我要把它发到我们的故事里，因为我找到了。我就是说不好“更精细的事物”、“更精细的”、“上流社会俱乐部”，该死！而且你还会了解到，安吉拉·马丁一直在镇压其他俱乐部，她真的很生气，因为上流社会俱乐部没有得到聚会策划委员会的批准。哇。你还得让你的俱乐部得到批准？
Apparently, you have to get them sanctioned by the party planning committee and she has squashed other renegade groups. Meredith is so mad that she's not asked to be in the Finer Things Club. She has her big gulp from 7-Eleven that I'm sure is full of adult beverage, throws it on the ground. Really? People are hot and bothered that they haven't been invited. Well, here's who's in the club, Pam, Oscar, and Toby.
显然，你必须得到聚会策划委员会的批准，而且她已经镇压了其他非主流团体。梅雷迪思非常生气，因为她没有被邀请加入上流社会俱乐部。她手里拿着从7-Eleven买的大号饮料杯，我敢肯定里面装满了成人饮料，然后把它摔在地上。真的吗？人们因为没有被邀请而感到恼火。好吧，俱乐部成员有：彭妮、奥斯卡和托比。
And here's what they do in the Finer Things Club. They celebrate books, art, and culture, but there is no paper, no plastic, and no work talk allowed. Pam says in her talking head, it's very exclusive. I also love, Jenna, that we learn that Oscar does not care for Jim's comedy, doesn't care for his bits because he doesn't want Jim in the club, because Jim does comedy bits that really made me laugh. This is the thing I love about our show.
以下是他们在上流社会俱乐部做的事情。他们庆祝书籍、艺术和文化，但绝对不准谈论纸张、塑料和工作。彭妮在独白中说，这非常排外。詹娜，我还喜欢一点，我们了解到奥斯卡不喜欢吉姆的喜剧，不喜欢他的小段子，因为他不想让吉姆加入俱乐部，因为吉姆总是表演那些真的把我逗笑的喜剧段子。这就是我喜欢我们节目的地方。
There is an assumed history. We don't go into it, but just know that Oscar has had it with Jim's little bits that he does. Yeah. I love everything about the Finer Things Club. I was in a book club and we would have themed dinners based on the books. Very similar to what we see the club doing. Oh my gosh, amazing.
这里有一段默认的历史。我们没有深入探讨，但只要知道奥斯卡已经受够了吉姆演的那些小段子就行了。是的。我喜欢关于上流社会俱乐部的一切。我以前加入过一个读书俱乐部，我们会根据书本举办主题晚宴。这跟我们看到的俱乐部做的事情非常相似。哦，天哪，太棒了。
And by the way, we had a fan question from Jennifer Good. She said, can you talk about how you film a montage like the one with the Finer Things Club? Do you film it all at once and just change your clothes in between to make it look like different days? How does that work? Well, yes, Jennifer, that's exactly what we did. We took a whole morning and we would dress up in our little outfit and they would set
顺便说一句，我们收到了詹妮弗·古德的粉丝提问。她说，你们能聊聊如何拍摄蒙太奇片段吗？比如上流社会俱乐部那个。是一次性拍完，然后在中间换衣服来假装是不同的日子吗？那是怎么运作的？好吧，是的，詹妮弗，那就是我们所做的。我们花了一整个上午，穿着我们的小衣服，他们会为一个小段子布置休息室
up the break room for one bit and then we would film it and we'd go back to our trailers and while we changed clothes, they would change the set. And we just did that until we had all of the different montage pieces. Yes. And the rest of us got a late start that day. We had late call times. Well, Jenna, here's the Finer Things Club reading list and a little bit about their art and music selection.
，然后我们拍摄它，接着我们回到化妆车里，在我们换衣服的同时，他们会重新布置布景。我们就这样一直重复，直到拍完了所有不同的蒙太奇片段。是的。我们其他人那天开工比较晚。我们的通告时间比较晚。好吧，詹娜，这是上流社会俱乐部的书单，还有一些关于他们的艺术和音乐选择的信息。
They are currently reading A Room with a View, which is a novel by E.M. Forster. In flashbacks, we see them reading The House of Spirits, also known by its original title as La Casa de los Espíritos. It's by Isabel Allende. Then they are reading Memoirs of a Geisha by Arthur Golden. Jenna, I did a little bit of a deep dive of the painting they're analyzing at four minutes and four seconds. Ooh, what is it?
他们目前正在读《看得见风景的房间》，这是E.M.福斯特的一部小说。在闪回中，我们看到他们在读《幽灵之家》，原名为《La Casa de los Espíritos》。作者是伊莎贝尔·阿连德。然后他们在读阿瑟·高顿的《艺伎回忆录》。詹娜，我对他们在4分04秒分析的那幅画做了一点深入探讨。哦，那是什么？
It's also one of my favorite screen grabs of view I have ever taken. Okay. I might use it as my contact photo for you. Oh boy. Oscar is pointing at this painting. There's a debate. You're wearing berets. You're eating crepes and you are throwing your hand in the air.
这也是我截过的我最喜欢的屏幕截图之一。好吧。我可能会用它作为给你存的联系人照片。哦天哪。奥斯卡正指着这幅画。有一场辩论。你们戴着贝雷帽。你们在吃可丽饼，而你把手高高举在空中。
It's just wonderful. Okay. So I saw on a few sites that people were like, does anyone have any information about the painting of the Finer Things Club? I'm going to tell you. This painting is called Monet, Painting in His Studio Boat, 1874, by Eduard Manet. Hmm. It's a Manet of Monet.
简直太美妙了。好吧。所以我看到有些网站上有人在问，有人知道关于上流社会俱乐部那幅画的信息吗？我来告诉你。这幅画名为《莫奈在画室船上》，1874年，爱德华·马奈作。嗯。这是马奈画的莫奈。
Manet painted Monet. So Claude Monet and Eduard Manet were friends. They were artist friends and Claude Monet had this boat that he would go out in and he would paint and Manet painted his friend in his boat painting a picture. And I have seen it online mislabeled. For example, at Wayfair, they sell a print of this. They have it titled Monet, Painting in His Studio by Claude Monet. So I wrote Wayfair.
马奈画了莫奈。所以克劳德·莫奈和爱德华·马奈是朋友。他们是艺术家朋友，克劳德·莫奈有这样一艘船，他会划出去画画，而马奈画了他朋友在船上画画的场景。我在网上看到过它被贴错标签。例如，在Wayfair上，他们出售这张画的印刷版。他们将其命名为《莫奈在画室里》，作者是克劳德·莫奈。所以我写信给Wayfair了。
I wrote them. You wrote them? I did. I went into their comments and questions section and I said, you have this mislabeled. This is Monet, Painting in His Studio Boat by Eduard Manet. I look forward to seeing if that gets changed. I hope it does. You can go to www.manet.org to learn more about Eduard Manet.
我写信给他们了。你写信给他们了？是的。我进入了他们的评论和提问区，我说，你们这幅画的标签贴错了。这是爱德华·莫奈画的《莫奈在画室船上》。我期待看到这是否会被修改。我希望会。你可以访问www.manet.org了解更多关于爱德华·莫奈的信息。
This is a fan question from Lauren Harris, Debani T., Maria H., and Nicole P., wanting to know if I have read any of the books that were featured in the different clips from The Finer Things Club. I have read none of them. What? No. Lady, I have read A Room with a View, Memoirs of Agatia, and Angela's Ashes. Wow!
这是一个来自劳伦·哈里斯、德巴尼·T、玛丽亚·H和妮可·P的粉丝提问，想知道我是否读过上流社会俱乐部不同片段中出现的任何书籍。我一本也没读过。什么？没有。女士，我读过《看得见风景的房间》、《艺伎回忆录》和《安吉拉的灰烬》。哇！
How are they? I should be in The Finer Things Club. Wow! I have to say, watching this episode, I thought this is a good reading list. It is. I want to make a good book club. Yeah, the only one I haven't read is The House of the Spirits, but I want to because I read a little bit about what it's about and I think it's really interesting.
它们怎么样？我应该加入上流社会俱乐部。哇！我必须说，看完这一集，我觉得这是一份很好的书单。确实是。我想弄个好的读书俱乐部。是的，我唯一没读过的是《幽灵之家》，但我想读，因为我稍微了解了一下它的内容，我觉得它真的很有趣。
Should we read it together? Oh my gosh, should we do a book club of The House of the Spirits? Well, I've really been reading a lot of non-fiction this past year and I am on the lookout for a great couple of fiction books. So maybe this is where I should start. Okay. I'm inspired. So maybe The House of the Spirits, Jenna, let's start a little book club.
我们应该一起读吗？哦，天哪，我们应该办一个《幽灵之家》读书俱乐部吗？嗯，过去这一年我真的读了很多非虚构类作品，我正在寻找几本很棒的小说。所以也许这正是我应该开始的地方。好的。我被启发了。所以也许就读《幽灵之家》，詹娜，我们办个小读书俱乐部吧。
Let's do it. Who wants to read it with us? Read it with us. Kim would be called The Finer's Things Club. Yes. Ours is called The Finer's Things Club in honor of Angela because I won't ever get it right otherwise. I like it.
行动起来。谁想和我们一起读？和我们一起读吧。俱乐部可以叫“更精细的事物俱乐部”。是的。为了向安吉拉致敬，我们的俱乐部就叫“更精细的事物俱乐部”，因为否则我永远也记不住正确的名字。我喜欢。
Well now, Michael has called Karen. He starts the call with Philip Hallers. How they hanging? Yeah. Way to go, Michael. And he tells her, look, I'll give you Toby. You can't take Stanley. Take Toby.
现在，迈克尔给凯伦打了电话。他在电话开头说：“菲利普·霍勒斯。最近怎么样？”是的，干得好，迈克尔。他告诉她，听着，我把托比给你。你不能带走斯坦利。把托比拿去。
And then he can't even get through it. He's trying to upsell Toby. He's like, he's smart. He's like, forget it. Toby's the worst. And then he says, you know what? If you take Stanley, I'm going to take your best salesperson. She's like, goodbye, Michael.
然后他甚至无法坚持下去。他试图推销托比。他说，他很聪明。他接着说：算了吧。托比是最糟糕的。然后他说，你知道吗？如果你带走斯坦利，我就去把你的王牌销售员挖走。她说，再见，迈克尔。
And he's like, wait, before you go, can you just transfer me to your best salesperson? I know. And she hangs up on him. So Pam connects Michael with Utica's Top Salesperson, and Michael pitches him a job in Scranton. Ben Nugent, Top Salesperson, and Utica. We had a fan question about Ben Nugent, Angela, from Amanda Massa, Jennifer Neal, and Casey Kraft, who is the voice of Ben Nugent from Utica.
他说，等一下，在你挂断之前，能把我转给你们的王牌销售员吗？我知道。然后她挂断了他的电话。于是彭妮把迈克尔接通到了尤蒂卡的王牌销售员那里，迈克尔向他推销了斯克兰顿的一份工作。本·纽金特，尤蒂卡的王牌销售员。关于本·纽金特，我们收到了来自阿曼达·马萨、珍妮弗·尼尔和凯西·克拉夫特的粉丝提问，尤蒂卡的本·纽金特是谁配音的？
Well, guys, it was our writer, Lester Lewis. Oh, oh, I didn't know that. I love hearing that. Yeah. Ben Nugent, the character, was named after Mindy Kaling's real-life boyfriend at the time, writer Benjamin Nugent. I remember them dating. That didn't even register when I was watching this.
好吧，伙计们，那是我们的编剧莱斯特·刘易斯。哦，哦，我不知道那个。很高兴听到这个。是的，本·纽金特这个角色是以敏迪·卡林当时的现实生活男友、编剧本杰明·纽金特的名字命名的。我记得他们约会过。我当时看的时候甚至都没注意到这一点。
Yeah. Oh my gosh. Wow. That's some good little tidbits there, Jenna. Well, I love how Michael starts this call with him. He said, hey, do you like magic? Because I'm a genie in a bottle. And I'm going to grant you three wishes, to move to Scranton, to have a great job, and
是的。哦，天哪。哇。那里有一些很好的小花絮，詹娜。好吧，我喜欢迈克尔开始这通电话的方式。他说，嘿，你喜欢魔法吗？因为我是瓶中精灵。我要满足你三个愿望，搬到斯克兰顿，找到一份好工作，
to be my best friend. Cuckoo pants. I know. Could you imagine getting a call like that? No. And of course, Ben just shuts him down. He's like, yeah, I heard you're the guy that hit a woman with a car. Like, he's just not into it.
还有成为我最好的朋友。疯子。我知道。你能想象接到那样的电话吗？不能。当然，本直接拒绝了他。他说，嘿，我听说你就是那个开车撞了个女人的家伙。总之，他一点也不感兴趣。
And this is when Michael has this talking head where he says, Scranton isn't lame. It's cool. We're like the fun branch. And that's where that extended talking head would have come, where he breaks down all the branches. Oh, amazing. Michael and Dwight storm into the break room where the finer things club is setting up. They have some Vivaldi playing in the background.
这就是迈克尔发表独白的时候，他说斯克兰顿一点也不逊色。它很酷。我们就像是有趣的分社。也就是在那里，那段扩展的独白本该出现，他在那段独白里剖析了所有的分社。哦，太棒了。迈克尔和德怀特冲进了上流社会俱乐部正在布置的休息室。背景里放着维瓦尔第的音乐。
The scene is so funny. I don't know how you guys got through it, but you couldn't. I saw the bloopers. You guys were losing it. Listen, every time Toby walks in and he's wearing his bow tie and Michael reacts to him, Paul could not get through that moment. He laughed every time Steve looked at him. It took us so long to get through that.
那个场景太搞笑了。我不知道你们是怎么拍完的，但你们肯定拍不下去。我看过失误镜头。你们当时笑疯了。听着，每次托比走进来，戴着他的领结，迈克尔对做出反应时，保罗都无法熬过那一刻。每次史蒂夫看着他，他都会笑。我们花了那么长时间才拍完。
It was so funny. You guys have to watch these bloopers. He's walking in with like stacked china tea cups. And there is a time that Steve broke, which you guys know was rare, but Steve completely broke and one of the bloopers, Paul is Toby just says bow tie. It was so amazing. It is so good. Well, anyway, the purpose of the scene was that Dwight and Michael full on lie to Jim.
这太搞笑了。你们一定要看看这些失误镜头。他走进来时端着一叠中国茶杯。有一次史蒂夫笑场了，你们知道这很少见，但史蒂夫完全笑场了，其中一个失误镜头里，保罗扮演的托比只是说了句“领结”。这太惊艳了。真的太棒了。不管怎样，这个场景的目的是德怀特和迈克尔对吉姆撒了弥天大谎。
So Michael and Dwight have this whole ruse to get Jim to go to Utica with them. They tell them that this company has lost the staples account and they're going to go and they're going to get it and Jim has to come with them. So off they go. Yeah. Yeah. So they're in the car. Jim notices.
所以迈克尔和德怀特设下了这个整个骗局，好让吉姆跟他们一起去尤蒂卡。他们告诉吉姆，这家公司丢掉了订书钉客户，他们要去把它拿回来，而吉姆必须和他们一起去。于是他们出发了。是的。他们在车里。吉姆注意到了。
Oh, no, wait. You missed the exit. And that's when Dwight and Michael are like, we have a surprise for you. Jim is immediately, immediately terrified. The look on Rain's face in the backseat is Dwight. He could barely contain like how giddy he was that they roped Jim into this. And Michael's like, we're going on a panty raid to Utica. My God.
哦，不，等等。你错过了出口。就在这时，德怀特和迈克尔说：“我们有个惊喜给你。”吉姆立刻，马上吓坏了。雷恩坐在后座上的表情是——他是德怀特。他几乎无法掩饰把吉姆卷入其中的兴奋劲。迈克尔说：“我们要去尤蒂卡进行一次突袭内裤行动。”天哪。
Oh my gosh. And Jim's like, no, no, he gets out his cell phone. He's going to make a phone call, but Dwight grabs it and throws his phone out the window. Yeah. Throws his phone out the window. And also Michael says, had to be done. Had to be done. What?
哦，天哪，吉姆说，不，不，他掏出手机。他正要打电话，但德怀特一把抢过手机，把它扔出了窗外。是的。把他的手机扔出了窗外。而且迈克尔还说，不得不这么做。不得不这么做。什么？
What? We had a fan question from Icy Lee and Emily Jones. When they threw Jim's phone out the window, did someone have to go pick it up behind the car? Was that a real phone? Okay. It was a real phone. And yes, we had a follow car, which is a car that follows the actors and they would have
什么？我们收到了来自艾西·李和艾米莉·琼斯的粉丝提问。当他们把吉姆的手机扔出窗外时，是不是得有人去车后捡回来？那是真手机吗？好吧。那是真手机。是的，我们有一辆跟随车，就是一辆跟着演员的车，他们不得不
to stop and pick up that phone. Yeah. We had a fan catch from Doug Schmidt, who says, not a question, but when Dwight throws Jim's phone out the window, they are clearly on a four lane road. But when they stop to find it, it's only a two lane road. Oh, look at you with your catch, Doug, you go. And another catch from Emily Ambriss at eight minutes, 45 seconds, when they've stopped to retrieve the phone, you can see a road sign that says San Fernando in a fourth of
停下来去把那个手机捡回来。是的。我们收到了来自道格·施密特的粉丝抓包，他说，不是问题，但当德怀特把吉姆的手机扔出窗外时，他们明显是在一条四车道公路上。但当他们停下来去找它时，它变成了一条两车道公路。哦，瞧瞧你这犀利的抓包，道格，真有你的。来自艾米莉·安布里斯的另一个抓包，在8分45秒，当他们停下来找手机时，你可以看到一个路标，上面写着“四分之一英里处到圣费尔南多”。
a mile. Oh, that's a really good catch. So yeah, clearly in California. So they're looking for Jim's phone, Jim finds it and he's like, you know what, I'm gonna call a cab. And they're like, okay, well, you'll miss out on the pranks. And he's like, hold up. What are you guys doing?
哦，那真的是个很棒的抓包。所以，是的，显然是在加利福尼亚州。所以他们正在找吉姆的手机，吉姆找到了，他说，你知道吗，我要叫辆出租车。他们说，好吧，那你会错过恶作剧的。他说，等等。你们打算干什么？
What do you have planned? Michael Lissoff, they have the warehouse uniforms, silly string. Dwight also has some gasoline and chunks of rubber to make stink bombs or real bombs. They don't know. Yeah. Could be badass. They don't know. It could be either one.
你们有什么计划？迈克尔下车了，他们穿着仓库工人的制服，拿着彩带。德怀特还带了一些汽油和橡胶块来做臭气弹或者真正的炸弹。他们不知道。是的。可能会很厉害。他们不知道。两者都有可能。
And Jim's like, yeah, no, that's not happening. So he makes a deal with them that he'll dress up in the warehouse uniform. By the way, the one he got was Madge's. Yes. And that he will go with them, but no stink bombs or shenanigans. Yeah. This is the compromise that he makes. And from this talking head, it cuts to this silent moment in the car, nine minutes, 45
吉姆说，好吧，不，那可不行。所以他跟他们达成交易，他会穿上仓库工人的制服。顺便说一句，他拿的那套是马奇的。是的，他会跟他们一起去，但绝对不能有臭气弹或恶作剧。是的。这是他做出的妥协。从这段独白切到了车内的静默时刻，9分45
seconds. The three of them in the uniforms with these ridiculous mustaches. It is such a funny cut too. It cracked me up. I have so much to say about these car scenes, but I think we should take a break and come back and really get into it. Have you ever peed in a bottle in the backseat of a car? I have not.
秒。他们三个穿着制服，留着滑稽的小胡子。这个剪辑也太搞笑了。把我逗乐了。关于这些车内的场景我有太多话想说了，不过我想我们应该休息一下，回来后再深入探讨。你有没有在汽车后座的瓶子里尿过尿？我没有。
Have you? I thought about it real serious. I've peed on the side of a lot of roads. Same. Okay. Well, more to discuss when we come back. We are back and the boys are in the car. They've got their outfits on.
你呢？我很认真地考虑过。我在很多路边尿过。一样。好吧，等我们回来后再讨论更多。我们回来了，这几个家伙在车里。他们穿上了衣服。
They've got their mustaches on. They're driving to Utica. Michael is asking Jim a lot of questions about his breakup with Karen. And Jim doesn't want to talk about it. So Jim is like, let's play that alphabet game that you want to play. Yes. And Michael's like, okay, A is for Alan and he's married to Allison. They live in Alaska and they sell, ah, what do they sell?
留着小胡子。他们正开车去尤蒂卡。迈克尔问了吉姆很多关于他和凯伦分手的事。吉姆不想谈这个。所以吉姆说：“来玩你想玩的那个字母接龙游戏吧。”是的。迈克尔说：“好，A代表艾伦，他娶了艾莉森。他们住在阿拉斯加，他们卖……啊，他们卖什么？”
What do they sell? And then he's like, wait, what is that noise? I hear, is that water like in the engine? Like what is that air conditioner leaking? What's that sound? Oh, that sound is Dwight peeing in a can in the backseat. And they freak out. They're like, oh gross.
他们卖什么？然后他说：“等等，那是什么声音？我听见，是发动机里有水吗？就像那个空调在漏水？那是什么声音？”哦，那个声音是德怀特在后座的罐子里撒尿。他们吓坏了。他们说：“哦，太恶心了。”
And then Michael starts swerving and Dwight's like, you're making me spray. The scene is like so fun to watch. I was laughing so hard. We got a lot of mail about the scene. One from Sadie Kay who says, when the guys were in the car, did they break a lot? Oh Sadie, the bloopers from the scene are so worth it. You've got to watch it. They were cracking up.
然后迈克尔开始打方向盘，德怀特说：“你让我喷出来了。”这个场景看起简直太逗了。我笑得前仰后合。我们收到了很多关于这个场景的邮件。一封来自萨迪·K，她说，当这几个家伙在车里时，他们笑场了很多次吗？哦，萨迪，这个场景的失误镜头太值得看了。你一定要看。他们当时笑得前仰后合。
I mean, it's one of the like rare times where Steve could not keep it together. Steve. Yeah. Every time too. Rain would have to say, I think I cut my penis on the lid. And then this is in the deleted scenes, but it's also in the bloopers. At the very end Dwight goes, I cut a chunk out of my penis for nothing. Those guys could not get through it.
我的意思是，这是史蒂夫无法控制自己的极少数时刻之一。史蒂夫。是的。每次都是这样。雷恩不得不说：“我觉得我的阴茎被盖子割破了。”然后这些在删减片段里有，但也出现在失误镜头里。在最后，德怀特说：“我的阴茎被割掉了一大块，白费了。”这几个家伙根本拍不下去。
They were like melting into laughter. I mean, just imagine being in a car together. These three comedic actors at the top of their game. I mean, brilliant. We had another fan question from Evan Derrickson. This is a technical question. Evan wants to know who got to decide who wears which mustache because they're really perfect for each character and so funny.
他们笑得快融化了。我的意思是，想象一下挤在一辆车里。这三位喜剧演员正处于他们职业生涯的巅峰。我的意思是，太绝了。我们收到了来自埃文·德里克森的另一个粉丝提问。这是一个技术问题。埃文想知道是谁决定谁戴哪种小胡子的，因为它们真的太适合每个角色了，而且非常搞笑。
Is that a wardrobe thing? Does it need Greg's approval? Is it props? Well, Evan, I like your question because you've clearly been listening to Office Ladies. The mustaches are made by hair and makeup. So it's not a prop and hair and makeup work together because it's hair because it's a mustache, right?
那是服装部门决定的吗？需要格雷格的批准吗？是道具吗？好吧，埃文，我喜欢你的问题，因为你显然一直在听《办公室》女郎。小胡子是由发型和化妆部门制作的。所以这不是道具，发型和化妆部门一起合作完成的，因为它是头发，因为它是个胡子，对吧？
Yeah. But then it goes on the face and has to be applied to the face. So it becomes a makeup thing. So they just had a tray of a bunch of different mustaches and yes, they got Greg's approval. They talked to Joss Whedon, the director. They talked to Mindy Kaling and they picked the mustaches for each of these guys to wear. Hair and makeup would take photos of the guys with the different mustaches and then walk them over to the writer's room and the writers and directors would look at it.
对。但随后它要贴在脸上，必须贴在脸上。所以这就成了化妆部门的事。因此，他们只是准备了一托盘各种各样的小胡子，是的，他们得到了格雷格的批准。他们跟导演乔斯·韦登谈过。他们跟敏迪·卡林谈过，然后为这几个家伙挑选了各自要戴的小胡子。发型和化妆师会拍下这几个家伙戴着不同小胡子的照片，然后把它们拿到编剧室，让编剧和导演们过目。
I can't imagine. That is so funny to me. Well, next up, the finer things club meeting is underway. Yes. And at 10 minutes, 50 seconds, we have a Pam's teapot catch. Yes. That's right. They are using Pam's teapot that Jim gave her in that very first Christmas episode.
我简直不敢想象。这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，接下来，上流社会俱乐部的会议正在进行中。是的。在10分50秒，我们迎来了彭妮的茶壶抓包。是的。没错。他们正在使用吉姆在那个第一个圣诞节送给彭妮的茶壶。
I have a question for the finer things club. Yes. How much stuff do you have to bring to work? On the day that you guys meet, there is a three tiered tray of sandwiches, a tablecloth, flatware, the teapot, the cups. You're like bringing a crate of stuff. Yeah. Don't worry about it.
我有一个关于上流社会的问题。是的。你们得带多少东西去上班？在你们聚会的日子里，有一盘三层的三明治、一块桌布、餐具、茶壶、杯子。你们简直像带了一箱东西去。是的。不用担心。
It doesn't involve you. We got it covered. They're discussing a room with a view and who walks in, but Andy. He wants to be in the club. And Pam tells him it's a closed club. She's very direct and unapologetic. I'm sorry. This is a closed club.
这跟你没关系。我们都搞定了。他们在讨论《看得见风景的房间》，谁走了进来？安迪。他想加入俱乐部。彭妮告诉他这是一个封闭的俱乐部。她非常直接，毫不退缩。抱歉。这是一个封闭的俱乐部。
And Andy has a talking head where he says the finer things club is the most exclusive club in the office. So it's naturally where he needs to be. Every planning committee is his backup, Kevin's band is his safety. Everything is like he's rushing a fraternity. It's so true. It's so true. Well, I'll have you know, we loved shooting these scenes, me, Oscar, Paul, we were delighted
安迪有一段独白，他说上流社会俱乐部是办公室里最排外的俱乐部。所以这自然是他需要呆的地方。每一个策划委员会都是他的备选，凯文的乐队是他的安全网。一切都像是他在赶着加入兄弟会。千真万确。千真万确。好吧，不妨告诉你，我们非常喜欢拍摄这些场景，我、奥斯卡、保罗，我们对这个故事情节感到欣喜若狂。
by the storyline. We had the best time because this was a group of people that did not normally get to hang out. I did not have a lot of scenes with Oscar or Paul. So this was really cool, and I'll have you know that before the pandemic, we had a finer things club reunion lunch. You did. I thought this was so, so sweet.
我们度过了最棒的时光，因为这是一群平时不怎么有机会聚在一起的人。我和奥斯卡或保罗没有很多对手戏。所以这真的很酷，而且我要告诉你，在大流行之前，我们举办过一次上流社会俱乐部的重聚午餐。真的。我觉得这太甜太甜了。
When you told me you guys were all going to meet, I was like, that is adorable. Yeah. We met, we had lunch, and we invited Ed. Oh. We let Ed come. So the four of us had this amazing lunch. I took a picture, so I'll post it in the pod. That is so sweet.
当你告诉我你们所有人都要见面时，我就想：这太可爱了。是的。我们见面了，吃了午餐，我们还邀请了安迪。哦。我们让安迪来了。所以我们四个吃了这顿丰盛的午餐。我拍了一张照片，所以我会把它发到播客里。太甜了。
I'm very sad. We were delighted on the show or in real life. Well, I'll say we did not discuss any literature or art at our reunion lunch. We just chatted about our lives and our kids. Well, now the guys have rolled up to the Utica branch, but Jenna, first I want to talk to you about a deleted scene. You will not believe this scene. I had Sam pull this clip.
我很难过。我们在节目里还是在现实中感到欣喜若狂。好吧，我要说的是，我们在重聚午餐上没有讨论任何文学或艺术。我们只是闲聊了各自的生活和孩子。好吧，现在这几个家伙开着车来到了尤蒂卡分社，不过詹娜，首先我想跟你聊聊一个删减片段。你绝对不会相信这个场景。我让山姆把这段剪辑拿出来了。
Jim has called Pam from the road with Michael and Dwight, and Pam is kind of passive aggressively given Jim a little shade for seeing Karen. Oh, I don't even remember doing this scene. I couldn't believe it. It just doesn't even sound like Pam to me. And I think there's a reason it was deleted, but it's pretty delicious to listen to. Sam, can you play it? Wait, you're going along with this now?
吉姆在和迈克尔和德怀特在路上时给彭妮打了电话，彭妮对吉姆和凯伦见面表现得有点被动攻击，带点酸溜溜的醋意。哦，我甚至都不记得拍过这个场景。我简直不敢相信。这听起来甚至都不像彭妮会说的话。我觉得它被删掉是有原因的，但听起来确实挺带劲的。山姆，你能播放它吗？等等，你现在顺着他们胡闹？
I have to. Pam, if I'm not there, someone's going to go to jail or die. Right. And you wouldn't be able to talk to Karen. Well, I promise you that has nothing to do with it. A little bit. Well, yeah, I don't want to see her get physically harmed, that's for sure. Because you love her?
我必须这么做。彭妮，如果我不在，有人会进监狱或死掉。对啊。然后你就没法和凯伦说话了。好吧，我向你保证这跟那毫无关系。有一点点。好吧，是的，我可不想看到她受到肉体上的伤害，那是肯定的。因为你爱她？
Because you love her very much? All right, I'm going to go now. Okay, have fun with your girlfriend. Okay, I will. I mean, Jenna, you're going to have fun with your new girlfriend? Oh my gosh, Pam is totally jealous. I don't know, do you think she's really jealous? Yes, Pam also has a talking head where she's like, I was just kidding, we kid like that.
因为你非常爱她？好了，我要挂了。好吧，祝你和你的女朋友玩得开心。好吧，我会的。我的意思是，詹娜，你要和你的新女朋友玩得开心吗？哦，天哪，彭妮完全吃醋了。我不知道，你觉得她真的是在吃醋吗？是的，彭妮还有一段独白，她好像在说，我只是开玩笑，我们经常那样开玩笑。
And then she's like, okay, maybe I'm a little jealous. Wow, I don't even remember shooting that. Yeah. That's so crazy. You have to watch the deleted scenes. That does sound a little bit like me when I'm being passive aggressive. That was more Jenna than Pam. Maybe a little bit.
然后她说，好吧，也许我有点吃醋。哇，我甚至都不记得拍过那个了。是的。这太疯狂了。你必须看看这些删减片段。那听起来确实有点像我表现出被动攻击的时候。那比起彭妮，其实更像是詹娜。也许有一点吧。
I think it's good that they deleted it because I think I like instead, you know, that he comes back at the end of the day and, you know, I don't know, I don't want to see that side of Pam. Yeah, I just don't think we need that tension in the relationship. It doesn't need to be about that, you know? Yeah. I like it and we'll get to it that Jim and Karen are going to have a moment where they have to deal with their stuff, but I like that Pam is left out of it.
我觉得他们删掉它是件好事，因为我觉得我更喜欢相反的设计，你知道的，他一天结束时回来，而且，我不知道，我可不想看到彭妮的那种一面。是的，我只是觉得我们不需要在那种关系中制造这种紧张感。没必要跟那个较劲，你知道吗？是的。我喜欢这样，我们马上就会看到吉姆和凯伦将不得不处理他们之间的事情，但我喜欢彭妮被排除在外。
Yeah, me too. So now the guys roll up to the Utica branch and Michael reveals their plan. They're going to pretend to be warehouse workers and they're going to silly string the whole place. Dwight adds that he might stab the security guy in the eye with a piece of jumbo chalk. And Jim is like, you're not stabbing anyone in the eye. Dwight's like, okay, fine. Maybe I'll just grind it up and blow it in his eyes.
是的，我也是。所以现在这几个家伙开着车来到尤蒂卡分社，迈克尔透露了他们的计划。他们要假装成仓库工人，然后用彩带喷遍整个地方。德怀特补充说，他可能会用一块巨型粉笔戳保安的眼睛。吉姆说：“你谁的眼睛也不许戳。”德怀特说：“好吧，好吧。也许我只会把它磨成粉末，吹进他的眼睛里。”
Yeah, he has a talking head that he says the eyes are the groin of the head. Yeah. So look out eyeballs of Dwight's around. I really love that line. I do too. Dwight and Michael leave and Jim is now on a walkie-talkie in the car. Well, and he sees Karen. He's like, oh my God, she's here.
是的，他有一段独白说眼睛就是头部的腹股沟。是的。所以如果德怀特在附近，眼睛可要小心了。我真的很喜欢那句台词。我也喜欢。德怀特和迈克尔离开了，吉姆现在正拿着对讲机坐在车里。好吧，他看到了凯伦。他说：“哦，天哪，她在那儿。
Go, go, go. And he leans the seat back trying to hide from Karen. Yeah. But in the meantime, through the walkie-talkie, we only hear it, which I personally think is so freaking funny. Michael and Dwight decide to steal the industrial copier, then you hear a very loud crashing noise, and then you start to hear Michael talking about his hip. He's saying, Jim, save us.
快，快，快。”他把座位往后放倒，试图躲开凯伦。是的。但与此同时，通过对讲机，我们只能听到声音，我个人觉得这简直太搞笑、太酷了。迈克尔和德怀特决定偷走那台工业复印机，接着你听到了一声非常巨大的撞击声，然后你开始听到迈克尔在谈论他的臀部。他在说：“吉姆，救救我们。”
He's saying, Jim, if this is my last moment, please tell me you'll take over the dundies. It's so, so amazing. And Jenna, you're so right. It was better over the walkie-talkie. There's a deleted scene in the stairwell where Michael is pinned by the copier and there's a silly string everywhere, and the security guards have come, and it just plays funnier over the walkie-talkie. It really does.
他在说：“吉姆，如果这是我的最后时刻，请告诉我你会接管丹迪奖。”这真的是太、太棒了。詹娜，你说得太对了。通过对讲机听起来效果更好。楼梯间里有一个删减片段，迈克尔被复印机压住了，到处都是彩带，保安也来了，通过对讲机播放感觉更搞笑了。确实如此。
So I was really glad that they made that choice. I have a fan catch for this moment. Okay. When the guys were driving in the car, it was very clear that there was just Michael, Jim, and then Dwight in the back seat. But now, all of a sudden, we have a camera operator in the car with Jim. Yeah. And Jim is like, get down.
所以我很高兴他们做了那个选择。关于这个时刻，我有一个粉丝抓包。好的。当这几个家伙开车时，很明显车里只有迈克尔、吉姆，然后是坐在后座的德怀特。但现在，突然之间，车里多了一个摄像师跟着吉姆。是的。吉姆说：“趴下。
What are you doing? You know? Where did this guy come from? And also, when they're on the side of the road, there was clearly a camera operator on the side of the road with them. So I have made up a story in my head that the camera operators followed them in another vehicle to document this moment. They had a huge budget.
你在干什么？”你知道的。这家伙是从哪儿冒出来的？而且，当他们在路边时，路边明显也有一个摄像师跟着他们。所以我脑子里编造了一个故事，那就是摄像师们开着另一辆车跟在后面来记录这个时刻。他们的预算太充足了。
They put lipstick cameras in the car, rigged the car, then followed the car with a second set of handheld cameras. This PBS went all out. They really did. Well, they knew that this was going to be a good moment. Yeah. And a fan question from Eris Beth Cruz, Zufan Jarad, Colby Shannon, and Karo B. Were Jim Michael and Dwight actually talking through walkie-talkies?
他们在车里装了微型摄像头，对汽车进行了改装，然后用第二套手持摄像机跟在车后。这个PBS电视台真是下了血本。他们确实下了血本。好吧，他们知道这将是一个精彩的时刻。是的。来自埃里斯·贝思·克鲁兹、祖凡·杰拉德、科比·香农和卡罗·B的粉丝提问。吉姆、迈克尔和德怀特当时真的在通过对讲机对话吗？
Yes, they were. And I don't know if this was in the bloopers, Angela, but John was laughing so hard at what he was listening to. I remember him telling me stories, wait until you see the scene. These guys were so funny over the walkie-talkie. I loved when Jim kept saying, stop saying my name. Yes. Yes.
是的，他们是。我不知道这是否在失误镜头里，安吉拉，但约翰听着对讲机里的声音笑得前仰后合。我记得他跟我讲过故事，等你看这个场景就知道了。这几个家伙在对讲机里太搞笑了。我喜欢吉姆一直说：“别叫我的名字。”是的。是的。
Well, Karen spots Jim in the car and she walks over. So embarrassing. But then it leads into this amazing scene. She's got the three of them on a couch in her office. It 100% looks like three kids who've been called to the principal's office. Well, Karen is loving this. I mean, there's a whole talking head where she says, I cried for weeks over that guy. So yeah, it felt pretty good seeing him in this situation.
好吧，凯伦在车里发现了吉姆，她走了过来。太尴尬了。但随后这引出了一个精彩的场景。她把他们三个叫到了她办公室的沙发上。这100%看起来就像三个被叫到校长办公室的孩子。好吧，凯伦很享受这一切。我的意思是，有一整段独白，她说：“为了那个家伙，我哭了几个星期。”所以，是的，看到他陷入这种处境感觉挺爽的。
Yeah. The only person still wearing his mustache now is Dwight. Michael is defending his behavior. He is saying that he cares enough to fight for his employees. And if Stanley comes to Utica and she hurts one hair on his head, he will burn Utica to the ground. Yeah. Right, and Michael both say they will burn Utica to the ground.
是的。现在唯一还戴着小胡子的人是德怀特。迈克尔正在为自己的行为辩护。他说他足够在乎，所以要为他的员工而战。如果斯坦利来到尤蒂卡，而她伤了他的一根头发，他就会把尤蒂卡夷为平地。是的。没错，迈克尔两个都说他们要把尤蒂卡夷为平地。
Insane. So Karen sends Michael and Dwight away. She says, Jim, will you stay a moment? The principal kept one, let the other two go. Well now it's going to get personal. This is so cringy. She says, Jim, if you wanted to see me, you could have just called. And Jim's like, oh no, I didn't want to see you.
太疯狂了。所以凯伦把迈克尔和德怀特打发走了。她说，吉姆，你能留一会儿吗？校长留了一个，放了另外两个。好吧，现在事情要变得个人化了。这太尴尬了。她说，吉姆，如果你想见我，你直接打电话就行了。吉姆却说，哦不，我不是来找你的。
And he's like, not that I'm not happy to see you, but I know I was basically just here for the copier. Because I'm with Pam and things are going well and we're good. And she's like, oh, I'm so glad to hear that things are going so well for you. Yeah. Angela, we had a fan catch for this scene from Rachel Watkins at 17 minutes 27 seconds as Karen and Jim are having their one on one. Karen has a photo of Hillary Clinton on her bookshelf.
然后他说，倒不是我不想见到你，但我知道我基本上只是为了复印机才来的。因为我和帕姆在一起，一切都很好，我们很好。她说，哦，很高兴听说你们一切都很好。是的。安吉拉，我们在17分27秒找到了一个粉丝发现的细节，来自雷切尔·沃特金斯，当凯伦和吉姆进行一对一交谈时，凯伦的书架上有一张希拉里·克林顿的照片。
Rachel is wondering if this is a nod to Leslie Knope having framed photos of Hillary Clinton in her office for Parks and Recreation. You know what, Rachel? I don't know, but what a great catch. Yeah, I didn't catch that. I zoomed in on it. But speaking of Parks and Recreation, Angela, we had another fan question. A bunch of people wrote in, they said, how did you get Rashida Jones back for this?
雷切尔想知道这是否是在向《公园与游憩》中莱斯利·克诺普办公室里挂着希拉里·克林顿装裱照片致敬。你知道吗，雷切尔？我不知道，但真是个好发现。是的，我没注意到。我把镜头拉近了。不过说到《公园与游憩》，安吉拉，我们还有另一个粉丝提问。很多人写信来问，你们是怎么让拉什达·琼斯回来演这个的？
Wasn't she on Parks and Recreation at the time? She was. But you might remember that Parks and Rec was created by Mike Sher, who was one of the office writers. And so our production office just called over to their production office and they were able to clear her for one day of work. So she came and did this one shooting day at these offices for Utica, but we didn't get to see her.
她当时不是在拍《公园与游憩》吗？她是。但你可能记得，《公园与游憩》是由迈克·舒尔创作的，他是《办公室》的编剧之一。所以我们的制作办公室打电话给他们的制作办公室，他们批准了她一天的工期。所以她来到尤蒂卡这些办公室拍了这唯一的一天戏，但我们没能见到她。
We did not get to have a reunion with her at all because she was on location. I know. I just thought she crushed these scenes. She was so perfect in them. Well, Jenna, there's a whole lot happening back at Dunder Mifflin because the Fine or Things Club is trying to have their meeting. You know, they had to hang a sign. You have to think someone hangs a sign because events have happened, right?
我们根本没有和她重聚，因为她当时在外地。我知道。我只是觉得她演这些戏太棒了。她在里面的表现太完美了。好吧，詹娜，德曼·米夫林那边发生了很多事，因为精细事物俱乐部正试图开会。你知道，他们不得不挂一块牌子。你得想一定是发生了什么事，才有人挂牌子吧？
Yes. And the solution is a sign. So they have made a sign at 12 minutes 49 seconds. You can catch it. And it says, Fine or Things Club in progress, please be respectful. And Kevin comes in. He's trying to get something out of the vending machine. He's banging it back and forth.
是的。解决方案就是一块牌子。他们在12分49秒做了一块牌子。你可以看到。上面写着，精细事物俱乐部进行中，请保持尊重。凯文进来了。他正试图从自动售货机里拿点东西。他用力撞击着机器。
His butt is like right up against your chair. And my absolute favorite moment of all of the Fine or Things Club meetings is Phyllis and that dang microwave. How many buttons is she hitting? So many buttons. So many buttons and Oscar, he is so fantastic. The way he lets it amp up and start to bug him as he's trying to form his thought about his book sharing, right?
他的屁股几乎贴着你的椅子。所有精细事物俱乐部会议中，我绝对最喜欢的时刻是菲利斯和那个该死的微波炉。她到底在按多少个按钮？太多的按钮了。太多的按钮，而奥斯卡，他太棒了。当他试图组织关于图书分享的想法时，那种任由它哔哔作响并开始烦扰他的样子，对吧？
He wants to tell you guys about this book, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, and then finally he just snaps and he's like, what are you microwaving? And Phyllis says, Popcorn with her St. Louis accent. We had a lot of people write in and catch that 1349. You hear a solid Popcorn. This is me though, Jenna. I am Oscar. If you want to drive me crazy, have some beeping somewhere.
他想跟你们谈谈这本书，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，最后他终于崩溃了，喊道，你到底在用微波炉热什么？菲利斯带着圣路易斯口音说，爆米花。很多人写信并在13分49秒发现了这一点。你能听到一个结实的“爆米花”。不过这就是我，詹娜。我就是奥斯卡。如果你想把我逼疯，就在某处弄点哔哔声。
Something beeping makes me nuts. You know, I have to turn off the beeping on my washer dryer. I don't need that to keep going off. I know I put the laundry in. I know I'll take the laundry out eventually. I'll get to it. I don't need you alarming me to my dry laundry for the next 15 minutes off and on. I don't get why everything has to beep so much.
有东西哔哔叫会把我逼疯。你知道，我不得不关掉洗衣机烘干机的哔哔声。我不需要它一直响个不停。我知道我把衣服放进去了。我知道我迟早会把衣服拿出来。我会去处理的。我不需要你在接下来的15分钟里断断续续地提醒我衣服干了。我不明白为什么所有东西都要哔哔个不停。
The refrigerator beeps, the dishwasher beeps, the microwave beeps. My coffee maker beeps. It beeps when it's done and then it beeps when it turns itself off. So much beeping. Can we tone it down on the beeping, appliance people? Not everything needs an alarm. You know? This is, we feel strongly about it.
冰箱会哔哔，洗碗机会哔哔，微波炉会哔哔。我的咖啡机也会哔哔。它煮好时会哔哔，关机时也会哔哔。太多的哔哔声了。电器界的人士，能不能把哔哔声调小一点？不是每样东西都需要闹钟的。你知道吗？对此我们深有感触。
We clearly feel strongly about all the beeping, unnecessary beeping. Who knew? Well, the guys get back from Utica. Michael gives Stanley his blessing. He says, you know what? It's okay. And then he gets him a box from the mail cart, Angela. The seldomly used mail cart is getting used.
我们显然对所有的哔哔声、不必要的哔哔声深有感触。谁知道呢？好吧，小伙子们从尤蒂卡回来了。迈克尔给了斯坦利他的祝福。他说，你知道吗？没关系。然后他从邮件车上拿了一个盒子给安吉拉。那个很少使用的邮件车终于派上用场了。
And then he says, Pam, come in my office. I need to write a one ad. And here is Michael's ad that he's going to place for a new employee to take Stanley's place. Are you ready? Well, he's laying on the ground as he dictates this to you. I know. I mean, he has given up all hope.
然后他说，帕姆，进我办公室。我需要写个招聘广告。这是迈克尔要发布的寻找新员工来接替斯坦利的广告。准备好了吗？好吧，他一边向你口述，一边趴在地上。我知道。我的意思是，他已经彻底绝望了。
He has failed. And yes, what does he tell you? Wanted. Middle-aged black man with sass. Big butt. Bigger heart. I love that Michael used sass. I thought the same thing.
他失败了。是的，他对你说了什么？“诚招。有风情的中年黑人男性。大屁股。更大的心。”我喜欢迈克尔用了“风情”这个词。我也这么想。
And then Stanley's like, I never planned on leaving. I say crazy things sometimes. I was just bluffing and Michael called my bluff. Yeah. He just wanted a raise. He was hoping to leverage this job offer to get more money. And earlier when Michael has a meeting with him, he's like, what can I do to get you to stay?
然后斯坦利说，我从没打算离开。我有时会说些疯话。我只是在虚张声势，而迈克尔看穿了我的虚张声势。是的。他只是想要加薪。他希望利用这个工作机会来换取更多钱。之前迈克尔和他开会时，他还问，我怎么做才能让你留下来？
And he's like, money, money, but Michael doesn't have the budget. But as it turns out, Stanley's not really going to uproot his family. He's going to stay. Yeah, and him, you know, putting this out there to Michael to see if Michael would like, you know, meet his demands almost cost Utica getting burned to the ground. I know. Pam tells Jim, I'm really sorry, Rolando told me everything. I love it that the receptionists talk to one another.
斯坦利说，钱，钱，但迈克尔没有预算。但事实证明，斯坦利并不是真的要背井离乡。他会留下来。是的，他，你知道的，把这个抛给迈克尔，看看迈克尔是否会，你知道的，满足他的要求，差点导致尤蒂卡被夷为平地。我知道。帕姆告诉吉姆，真的很抱歉，罗兰多把一切都告诉我了。我喜欢前台接待员们互相聊天。
I love this so much that you and Rolando have this whole friendship that we don't even know about. I also thought it was pretty great that you said to Jim, how embarrassing. Yeah. I know. Well, when I was chatting with Adam about his time on the office, one of the things he mentioned was that while he was shooting this episode, Rain and Mindy both came up to him and said, we think you could come back.
我太喜欢这个了，你和罗兰多竟然有这样一段我们甚至都不知道的友谊。我也觉得你对吉姆说“多尴尬啊”这句很棒。是的。我知道。好吧，我和亚当聊他在《办公室》的经历时，他提到的其中一件事是，当他拍摄这一集时，雷恩和敏迪都走过来对他说，我们觉得你可以回来。
We like this Utica branch idea. We want to have you back and that he was so excited. And then of course, you know, I go back for lecture circuit. And we had a little fan catch about that. Caitlin Donahue, Sidney Matthews and Courtney Sage said, in this episode, Pam mentions that she and Rolando talk. But in lecture circuit, Michael introduces Pam to Rolando when they arrive. Is this a continuity error?
我们喜欢尤蒂卡分公司的这个想法。我们想让你回来，他当时超级兴奋。然后当然，你知道的，我又回去拍《巡回讲座》了。我们有个关于这个的小粉丝发现。凯特琳·多纳休、悉尼·马修斯和考特尼·萨奇说，在本集中，帕姆提到她和罗兰多会聊天。但在《巡回讲座》中，迈克尔在他们到达时才把帕姆介绍给罗兰多。这是个连续性错误吗？
You know, guys, I just think Michael doesn't know. Michael doesn't know that Pam has these relationships. Just like remember earlier, it's clear that Pam and Michael's mother talked to one another as well. Oh, I think there's so much that Michael doesn't know about even what Pam's job does. You know, like how about the fact that like, he's like, Pam, will you hold all my calls today? And Pam's like, sure, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
你知道吗，伙计们，我只是觉得迈克尔不知道。迈克尔不知道帕姆有这些人际关系。就像之前记得的那样，很明显帕姆和迈克尔的母亲也互相聊过。哦，我觉得迈克尔不知道的事情太多了，甚至连帕姆的工作内容他都不知道。你知道，比如他会说，帕姆，今天帮我接听所有电话好吗？而帕姆却说，没问题，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔，哔。
Like Michael doesn't know what Pam does. It's true. To make Jim feel better, Pam invites him to be in the finer things club. And the end of this episode is a flash forward to their next meeting where they are discussing Angela's ashes. And true to Jim form. He has to do a bit. Yep.
就像迈克尔根本不知道帕姆在做什么一样。确实如此。为了让吉姆感觉好点，帕姆邀请他加入精细事物俱乐部。这一集的结尾是快进到他们的下一次聚会，他们在那里讨论安吉拉的骨灰。正如吉姆的一贯风格，他必须搞个恶作剧。是的。
He's doing his Irish accent. Oscar just kind of looks at him and is like, did you get it all out? And then he hasn't read the book. Oh, Paul is so amazing in the scene. He's like, who's the main character? Jim is like, Angela, no, no, the ashes, no. And Pam just mouth. Sorry.
他正在学爱尔兰口音。奥斯卡只是看着他，仿佛在说，你闹够了吗？然后他还没读这本书。哦，保罗在这一幕里太棒了。他说，主角是谁？吉姆说，安吉拉，不，不，骨灰，不。而帕姆只是做口型说，对不起。
Well, there are two deleted Andy scenes that I want to discuss before we wrap up. They're about the finer things club and about how desperately he was trying to get in. Because you know, when Pam let Jim in, you saw Andy go, are you kidding me? Right? Yeah. So here are these two things that Andy does. There is a scene where Andy comes in to the break room to you guys and offers you an envelope full of cash, a donation, if you will.
好吧，在我们结束之前，我想讨论两个被删减的安迪场景。它们是关于精细事物俱乐部的，以及他是多么拼命地想加入。因为你知道，当帕姆让吉姆进去时，你看到安迪说，你在开玩笑吧？对吧？是的。所以这就是安迪做的这两件事。有一个场景是安迪来到茶水间找到你们，并给你们一个装满现金的信封，如果你愿意的话，算是一笔捐款。
There is a scene, Jenna, in the deleted scenes. And I think it would have come towards the end of the episode. You guys, the finer things club, walk up to Andy, you give him a sealed envelope. He opens it up. It's a letter telling him he has been put on the waitlist. And he is thrilled. He shared that he was waitlisted at Cornell and then his dad donated a whole building to the college.
詹娜，在被删减的场景中有一个情节。我想它本应该出现在这一集的尾声。你们，精细事物俱乐部，走到安迪面前，给了他一个密封的信封。他打开一看，是一封信，告诉他他被列入了候补名单。他激动坏了。他分享说他当年在康奈尔大学时就在候补名单上，然后他爸爸给学校捐了一整栋楼。
Oh, I see. Oh my gosh. Andy, we learn and deleted scenes was in fact on the waitlist. Delicious. Guys, that was Branch Wars. Thank you to Adam Jamal Craig for sending in those audio clips and thank you guys for your questions. Next week, Survivorman.
哦，我明白了。噢天哪。我们在被删减的场景中得知，安迪事实上曾在候补名单上。太妙了。伙计们，这就是“分公司大战”。感谢亚当·贾马尔·克雷格发来这些音频片段，也感谢大家的提问。下周，硬汉荒岛求生。
Oh, and in the meantime, we will start the Finers Things Club. And what are we reading? Our first book will be the House of the Spirits. Ordering now. We'll see you guys next week. Thanks guys. We'll see you next week. Hope you have a good one.
哦，与此同时，我们将启动精细事物俱乐部。我们要读什么？我们的第一本书将是《幽灵之家》。现在就订购。我们下周见。谢谢大家。我们下周见。祝你们过得愉快。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。